here with reaction all this fox news
contributor former republican
congressman
he's now reformed he's actually filled
out on the show i don't watch the show
when i'm away otherwise i'm not off
uh trey gowdy is with us sir good to see
you
when you look at the rhetoric of joe
police become the enemy
and we're going to redirect funds and
kamala's saying oh applauding 150
million cut in the lapd and now they're
assassinating
attempting to assassinate police
officers thousands injured
45 cops dead this year on the job
uh do you believe that rhetoric has an
impact
of course it does i mean you know the
media wants us to believe that only
republican rhetoric
that's the only thing that can incite
violence
sean we've had ten thousand arrests this
year
connected with the riders two billion
dollars in property damage
we've got mobs chanting we hope you die
to two police officers who were almost
executed in the line of work
while you got other folks blocking
access to emergency medical care
for those deputies and yet the new york
times and the washington post
and those on the left want us to believe
that these protests are mostly
peaceful if two billion dollars and 10
000 arrests
and chanting we hope you die is mostly
peaceful
i hope it doesn't ever get violent uh
but the reality is how do you have an
entire convention
and not mention the violence in city
streets how do they deny
somehow bifurcate their their twisted
socialist brains
into denying what we see before our
eyes happening and reject the help that
the president is begging them to take
he begged again last night on that
idiotic interview with uh
georgie they're terrified of their base
sean and it was only when it became
apparent apparent that they're
losing you know independent voters
middle of the road voters because they
refuse to acknowledge that the country
is on fire they don't want to alienate
their base they don't want to alienate
the people that are setting things on
fire and looting
innocent property and store owners so
that that's the conundrum they have do
we speak out against this and alienate
our base
um what the the only reason joe said
anything
is because the polls are tightening and
they're losing on the issue of public
safety
they thought they could run the pandemic
all the way through the election
and now the country's on fire and you've
got cops almost being assassinated
and you've got mobs chanting we hope you
die
even joe can't ignore that well i'm not
really sure because
it doesn't seem exactly there now i
don't know if you're getting the same
questions i'm getting
everywhere i go people agree disagree
what's up with joe
um i don't know i hire a lot of people
if you want to work in this industry you
better have some urgency
to work on my radio or tv show you know
why this is a hard job
and you got to be on your game i don't i
don't think i'd hire joe biden to work
on this show because i don't think he
has the energy to keep up i don't think
he has the energy to work in a busy
restaurant
you getting the same questions i'm
getting
uh i am getting that question but but
more than anything i'm getting who is
kamala harris uh because i think that
there is a very real
likelihood she will have a
disproportionate role in the
administration if he wins
we've seen pelosi put you know
coronavirus relief on hold
people are familiar with chuck schumer i
mean even if joe biden were to win he
will not be running government
you can watch an interview and it's
painful to watch
he will not be running the country even
if he prevails in november oh
ocasio-cortez i think she gave a very
honest statement
she's pretty much admitting man we can
manipulate the hell out of them
all right how'd you like hosting the
show
i missed you and so did your viewers
yeah but i'm grateful for the chance
not as easy as it look is it you know
anyway
well chaffetz can do it anybody can do
it yeah chaffetz can do it i mean come
on
that's a great point actually i'm going
to tell him that you said that all right
thank you
congressman